depuis l'annoncé par bombardier d'un
avertissement sur ses résultats les
analystes évoquent la possibilité d'une
vente de l'un ou l'autre des deux bras
de bombardier le nez le bord de l'eau et
analyste en transport bonsoir bonsoir on
a parlé cette semaine de négociations
entre alstom et bombardier
est ce que c'est possible cela possible
oui sans doute parce que il ya des
analyses qui ont mis un prix là dessus
on pourrait vendre bombardier transport
à 5 milliards et demi selon l'analyse la
banque td par exemple de ce faudrait
soustraire le montant dû à la caisse de
dépôt pour sa participation 30% alors
mais ça serait possible mais quand même
difficile dans certains domaines qui
sont assez complémentaires par exemple
alstom est un peu plus avancées en
termes de systèmes de communication de
guidage
ils ont par exemple un magnifique contre
pour l'automatisation de tout le réseau
de paris une ligne des documents outils
fonctionner en mode automatique
par contre ils ont des domaines où il se
recouvrent énormément par exemple ils
font les mêmes le même genre de trains
régionaux de très longues distances et
de ce côté là il faudrait que certaines
usines
certains viennent de biens vers redon
dante et discret d'être fermé et donc y
aurait des compressions des suppressions
d'emplois bref c'est un risque que je
peux l'impression qu alstom a annoncé
des compressions rapidement mais il ya
une offre excédentaire de produits
ferroviaires en europe les pays vont
remplacer les les prêts existants les en
construise pas beaucoup de nouveau parce
que tout est déjà pas mal desservies ce
film moderniser alors il ya trop
d'usinés trop de travailleurs également
alors ça serait bien que cette fusion
alors permettent de réduire l'offre
excédentaire mais ça serait très mal
parce que ça ferait beaucoup d'emplois
et donc il y aurait des enjeux
politiques certainement c'est sûr que le
gouvernement français doit pas aimer ça
en fait traditionnellement le
gouvernement français s'arranger pour
répartir les contres
entre les deux joueurs bombardier et
alstom 15 tomes avait un gros contrat on
s'arrangeait pour que alstom donne est
sous contrat à bombardier et vice versa
alors ce qui fait que la plupart des
grands contrats en france sont fait
parler d'eux en collaboration - du moins
pacifique
est-ce qu'il doit y avoir des
conséquences sur nos de notre usine en
tout cas principalement à la pocatière
pour bombardier et alstom et tout ça se
rétrécit oui et puis en fait on peut
parler aussi de celle de thunder bay
face et des usines qui travaille
essentiellement pour le marché local
on peut plus beaucoup et pour exporter
aux états unis comme on le faisait avant
alors donc temps que montréal va avoir
besoin de métro de différents systèmes
les usines de la pocatière va avoir du
travail
l'autoroute au camp même pas beaucoup
bombardier c'est ainsi ça pose un
problème pourtant derby parce que kate y
aura plus de contrôle sur les contres
sont donnés un autre compagnie les and
thunder bay risque fort d'infirmer
carrément parce que ils exportent à peu
près rien étant donné qu'on peut plus
exportée aux états unis pourtant on le
dit pendant un certain temps un bon
moment que le secteur ferroviaire avait
énormément d'avenir mais le bombardier
s'est mis a accumulé les problèmes qui
la mènerait jusqu'à une transaction
potentielle avec alstom web il ya des
problèmes de qualité depuis une dizaine
d'années chez bombardier en fait qu'ils
n'ont jamais été résolus
moi j'ai commencé à suivre sa dette
quand bombardier a eu des problèmes
le francilien et c'est souvent des
problèmes qui en apparence ont l'air un
peu bénin mais quand pratiques sont
épouvantables
des problèmes informatiques par exemple
le contrôle pour l'ouverture des portes
encore récemment new york on a eu un
problème de charlas qui peut encore
rêver lost et c'est très dessin le
francilien un père dit s'appeler trois
ans pourrait que le problème et ça a
coûté une fortune alors donc c'est ce
genre de problème là qui menacent
bombardier du côté aéronautique
il va se passer quoi mais en fait le
bombardier le choix ou bien on vend
2 enfin vendre ou fusionner les
transports ou bien on pourrait vendre
les produits nautiques en fait
aéronautique est plus facile à vendre
parce qu'ils font des profits et y'a pas
de problème de qualité au contraire mais
par contre il ya aussi une offre
excédentaire dans l'aéronautique et en
fait quand on regarde les joueurs là on
a parlé beaucoup de textron aux états
unis est déjà propriétaire de bell
helicopter pour les hommes chez nous ces
snobs beach graf et cas pas de gros
avions d'affaires comme ceux de
bombardier
donc les deux lignes pourraient se
combiner assez facilement sans perdre
d'emploi d'ailleurs mais bon est-ce que
textron voudrait on sait pas il ya
falcon avec dassault mais dassault va
peut-être vouloir mettre son argent
ailleurs dans un avion de combat plus
que dans des avions d'affaires et la 220
et la 220 bella le problème c'est que
airbus veut plus d'argent de deux de ses
investisseurs québécois essentiellement
bombardier et le gouvernement du québec
pour augmenter plus rapidement la
production de la 220 à méribel et
malheureusement bombardier doit payer un
tiers de la facture donc supposons que
ça coûte la leur musique que hazard ne
soit pas encore annoncé le montant
nécessaire dont elle a besoin
mais maintenant que c'est un milliard
bombardier va devoir trouver 300
millions uniquement pour permettre
l'augmentation de la production à
méribel et les profits vont venir plus
tard que prévu et vont peut-être moins
important que prévu bon alors des choix
cornélien pour ben may on serait les
résultats la mi-février merci dany bord
de l'eau merci au revoir